quick game called confessions we played  this with Ed Sheeran John Legend pink  favorites comfort food all potatoes oh  love that no doubt ever ever doubt I've  ever fallen off of has been because of  the potato mashed or french fry or  something to do with the potatoes  who is the most famous person in your  phone and what's the last thing you  called or texted them about  oh I don't know that many famous people  in my phone and I don't text so I just  call him up if I need something perfect  yeah  uh what is a quirk that drives your  friends or family a little bonkers I  don't know oh they don't ask  the talk to me  so used to talking I never know when to  quit but I talk a lot because I got a  lot to say